Việt Nam Airlines cho biết, hàng đã ghi nhận sự của bảo mật giữ liệu liệu quan đến nên tạng chăm sóc hết hàng chực tuyến,
giống một tập đoàn công nghệ toàn cầu cử cấp.
Ngay sau khi nhận được kánh báo, Việt Nam Airlines đã hình chung phối hợp với cơ quan chức năng,
các chuyên già an ninh mạng và đối tác công nghệ để điều tra sự cố, đánh giá phạm viện hưởng và tăng cường có biển pháp bảo vệ giữ liệu.
Đại diện hàng hàng đình đến thời điểm diện tài, các giữ liệu nhẹn cảm như thế tiến dụ,
thông tin thành quán, mật khẩu, hàng chình, hộ chíu và số dươi tài quản lu tất s mai s của khách hàng vẫn được bảo mật an quan.
Các hệ thống công nghệ thông tin nội bộ của Việt Nam Airlines không bị anh hưởng.
Đối với các khách hàng liên quan Việt Nam Airlines sẽ gửi thông bảo và hướng sản các biển pháp hỗ trợ cần thiết quả thu địa tờ.
Hẳng cũng quyết nghĩ khách hàng càng giác với các hình thức giả mào, thu địa tờ hoặc quốc loại đáng ngờ,
mạo dành Việt Nam Airlines không chia sẻ thông tin càng nhân, mạo OTP và không đăng đập và các hệ thống chưa được sắc thực.
Việt Nam Airlines gửi lời xí lối vì sự việc và những loại gọi thế gửi ra cho khách hàng.
Đồng thời, khẳng định luôn có việc bảo vệ thông tin càng nhân và quyền lợi của khách hàng là UTN hàng đầu.
Đồng thời cảm kết tiếp tục tăng cơn các biển pháp bảo mật, để đàn bảo an toàn xưa liệu và suy chiến điểm tin của hành khách.